a decisive moment in the race to be the
next prime minister arriving as ballots
land on tory doorsteps
liz trust the undisputed front-runner
hey charlie you're right rishi sunax
struggling to close the gap
tails never fails do you want to go
first or second i want to go first
please there we go an early victory for
the foreign secretary
but under the studio spotlight with 80
mostly undecided party members the tough
questions began the bank of england have
said that a recession is inevitable what
could you do to mitigate the impact of
this
well what the bank of england have said
today is of course extremely worrying
but it is not inevitable we can change
the outcome and we can make it more
likely that the economy grows and on the
foreign secretary's first big stumble
this week on public sector pay an
admission but no apology liz why did you
announce a well-researched and fully
costed policy in which you openly said
you valued the work of teachers nurses
and police officers in newcastle where i
work
less than you value those in guilford
for example why should we trust your
judgment immediately as there were
concerns expressed about this policy i
said we're not going ahead with it you
said
that public sector pay policy has been
misrepresented by the media
here's the proposal that you released
introduce regional pay boards tailoring
pay to the cost of living where civil
servants actually work saving up to 8.8
billion pounds per year so how have we
misrepresented you so far can i be clear
k
that i'm not going ahead with this you
can but you said you would because i'm
just clarifying because because of the
concerns that have been expressed a
quick fire round and a possible hostage
to fortune uh what's the naughtiest
thing you've ever done i'm certainly i'm
certainly not going to say that on tv oh
is it that naughty
well my daughters are watching so i
don't want them i don't want them
getting any ideas okay yeah
is there anything that you feel that you
would want to come clean with the
audience here in the studio and at home
because there's no one else listening so
it's all fine i can just tell anything
that you need to get off your chest
there are i can tell you okay there are
no skeletons in my closet
liz trust wants to be seen as a
candidate to change the course her own
path though hasn't run straight
you were a remainer
and now you're not you supported brits
to fight in ukraine then you didn't you
wanted to build on the green belt and
now you don't you wanted to abolish the
monarchy and now you don't you wanted to
arm taiwan and now i'm not sure if
you're saying whether you do or not you
wanted civilization so we do provide
them with those you wanted to cut civil
servants pay in the regions and then you
said you didn't
will the
real
liz trust please stand up
very much thank you thank you
brilliant then came the turn of the
former chancellor is there a point that
you would stand aside in this campaign
the quick answer is no
and that's because well thank you
you've been campaigning for a long time
and it was perfectly timed a cynical
motivation to try and get you into
number ten no that's just
simply not true so i was due to give a
speech with the prime minister the next
week and in the conversations about
putting that speech together on the
economy it was clear our differences
were too big to reconcile okay so that
was the reason plus i think let's not
look at the hit the bass with rose
tinted spectacles here everyone
remembers what was going on with chris
pincher
um how will you balance the need to
address the escalating cost of living
crisis particularly for those that are
on lower incomes
alongside the need to keep the economy
in good order the lights on the economy
are flashing red and the root cause is
inflation but from economics to a rare
test on foreign policy for the former
chancellor on the conflict in ukraine
boris johnson has um
really thrown himself into the cause i
think everybody might agree with that
he's regarded as a hero apparently in
ukraine that's what he tells us he
brandishes his missile launches we've
seen that are you really
tough enough to stand up to vladimir
putin
yes i'm tough enough and i'm already
delivering the measures that are
actually causing him the most trouble
thank you
the applause for the former chancellor
kept coming people feel
that you can't walk a mile in their
shoes because you're walking in your
prada shoes what would you say to them
i think the british people judge people
by their character and by their actions
not by their bank account
it looks to me as though mr tsunak
convinced you far more than ms trust
once again rishi sunak delivered on
detail but this contest may well be
decided on ideas from the instinct of
tory members he may have won the room
but the foreign secretary remains on
course to be the next prime minister ali
fortescue sky news